-Okay, so, last night,
two things happened.
I was a guest on "The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon"
and Jimmy had his
fantasy-football draft.
He was drafting against
the staff.
He asked me for some tips.
-I have no idea what I'm doing.
-Okay. I can help.
This is what I do.
-Yeah.
-We're colleagues now.
-You can e-mail me.
-I can?
-I'll get my number to you.
You'll text me. Yeah.
Wait. 'Cause, listen.
You have pick 2 this year.
-I have pick 2. That's big deal.
-Right. So, most likely,
Jonathan Taylor will go 1.
He's the Colts' running back,
had a great season last year.
So, my question to you is,
what kind of player are you?
Like, do you want to be
risk-averse
or are you gonna
swing for the fences?
Because I'm a believer in,
you know,
Ricky Bobby from
"Talladega Nights."
Like, if you ain't first,
you're last, right?
If I were you, at pick 2,
I'm taking Christian McCaffrey,
who's been hurt
the last two years,
but, when he is healthy,
has been the best player
in fantasy football.
So, again,
it's a risk/reward pick.
That's what I would do at 2.
That's who I have
ranked number 2.
By the way, do you want to win?
I mean, like, you can --
Because, like, yeah,
I mean, if you want to,
I will help you
crush your staff like a grape.
You know...
I gave him a couple of hints,
and then he sent me his draft
and said,
"Hey, grade it for me."
So, okay, Jimmy, here it goes.
I love your quarterback.
Lamar Jackson's gonna have
a monster season
as he chases that new contract.
You have Travis Kelce,
who I have as
the number-1 tight end
in fantasy.
Great. Your running backs --
you went with "CMC" at 2.
So, I love McCaffrey this year.
Plus, Ezekiel Elliott,
Elijah Mitchell, Antonio Gibson.
You have
four starting running backs.
Great depth there.
My concern is
your wide receivers.
A.J. Brown is more of
a number-2 wide receiver
than the number 1
that you have him as,
and I'm concerned about
Jaylen Waddle
and a new situation in Miami
with a lot more targets
to go around to guys like
Tyreek Hill and Chase Edmonds.
Ultimately, I give you a B-plus.
[ Ding ]
But here's the great news.
Wide receiver is the deepest
position in fantasy football,
so you and I -- we're gonna
work the waiver wire,
We're gonna upgrade
that wide-receiver position,
and we're gonna
bring home the title
as you crush your league
like a grape.